is called balanced ternary and what you
do is you write your number in base
three and then you replace all the twos
by minus ones
so let's do it
zero
is fixed
one
is fixed two in base three just says two
and the rule is replace all the twos by
minus ones so this is now minus one
three internally it's one naught so it
doesn't change four is
1 1 in ternary and it doesn't change
still four five is one two which becomes
one comma minus one now one comma minus
one means one three minus one so it's
two 6 is 2 0 which becomes minus 1 0
which is minus 3. let me
remind you we're writing numbers in base
3. so it's minus 1 comma 0 sub 3 which
means minus three
plus zero zero in the ones position in
one's position okay yep so it's minus
three seven is two one which becomes
minus one one so that's minus three plus
1 which is minus 2 and so on and if you
do this you get all the integers both
positive and negative exactly once it's
a way if
in a concise way of enumerating all the
num all the integers and if you look at
the graph it looks like this it looks
like star wars a scene from star wars oh
wow
yeah isn't that great yeah
look at them they're all the star
destroyers yeah yeah and that graph will
eventually as it expands out plot every
single
integer negative and positive yeah yeah
they're all there it just keeps going
wisteria so now the sequence is you take
n you write it in base 10 and you
subtract the product of the non-zero
digits one product is one subtract we
get zero two zero three zero very boring
up to nine
zero
because the number minus the product of
its digits is zero if there's only one
digit okay ten ten has one non-zero
digit one this product is so subtracted
and we get nine eleven has the product
is one so we get 10. 12 product is 2 and
we get 10. 13. i look at the product of
the non-zero digits and subtract it from
the number 10.
14
is 10 again and well let's jump forward
by the time we get up to 25 products of
digits is 10 so we subtract 10 from 25
and we get 15. so it's drastically
changed 26 subtract 12 from 26 and we
get 14.
and so on the graph looks like this i
call it wisteria because to a gardener
this looks very like wisteria purple
flowers you see
in the trees
nice it's like the droop gets bigger but
it never droops further than well you're
not subtracting very much because you're
looking at the product of the digits and
that's much less than what you started
with since the digits are all nine or
less
but once you start getting interesting
numbers like you know four thousand six
hundred and ninety two yeah so four
times six times nine times two is
whatever it is but it's not very big so
it's not it doesn't droop very far from
what you started with somebody like some
pretty big groups there well yes they
had a lot of big digits i like that yeah
wisteria
so this is the forest fire and the rule
is that we put down the
lexicographically earliest sequence
meaning you always pick the smallest
numbers if you have a choice go small
i'll just do it that's the easiest way
we start off when we have a choice pick
the smallest positive number so so far
we don't have anything to worry about so
i can pick a one it's got to be positive
okay i can put another one because it's
not a big deal the rule says you may not
have
three terms
that are in an arithmetic progression
meaning the difference between here and
here is the same as the difference
between here and here so a of i plus j
minus a of i must not equal a of i plus
two j minus a of i plus j we've got two
ones here i would like to put a one here
because that's the smallest legal move
but then the difference between then
these three terms if we did that
we'd have a one
and a one and a one and they would be
equally spaced that's not allowed okay
it's not allowed they jump by zero each
time equally spaced numbers with a
constant difference between them it's
not allowed so we go to the next term
there's nothing wrong with putting a two
there okay now what about the next one
well i could put a one there because
there's there's no conflicts we've put
in one there now what about here could i
put a one there
yes i could i can and therefore i must
because there are no three ones that are
evenly spaced yes let's go on you'll see
now
so the sequence begins one one two one
one now what can i put here you should
always ask can i put a one can you put a
one you start off can i put a one can i
put a two we can't put a one because
we'd have one one one
and that would be a violation of the
rule constant increment of zero three
equally spaced terms
can i put a two i think we can do a two
so we've got one one two one one two all
right what's the next term now could it
be a one well i think it's gonna be a
problem if we have a one because one to
four to seven we would have a one jump
of three and a one a jump of three
that's not allowed that would be an
arithmetic progression one one one at
three terms which are equally spaced
that can't be a one could it be a two
well yes
uh
are you sure it looks like it could be a
two
yeah
okay
two
nothing wrong
okay what about the next term could it
be a one well it can't be a one by the
same rule because we'd have two five
eight that would be a one one one no
forboden forbidden not allowed so it
can't be a one could it be a two well no
because then we'd have two two two okay
could it be a 3. well if it was a 3
now here we see something
a little bit more subtle if this was a 3
we would have 1 2 3
constant difference of 1
at 3 equally spaced points
no
it can't be a three but it can be a four
and it keeps going that's the sequence
it's well defined it's unique and it's
crazy
it looks like this here is a graph of it
it's actually been filtered out a little
bit the picture is very busy so one of
my friends sean gregg removes some of
the the blackness from it so it looks
like this this is a hundred thousand
terms and you notice there's this
pattern of smoke which is repeating it
has a fractal structure and we do not
have any explanation for that you think
wow this is such an elegant definition
what's going on
no one has analyzed this
what do you mean by no one's analyzed
what do you want them to find out about
it like what would what would be well
you could say for instance what we have
here is something like the easter island
heads that get bigger and bigger and
bigger and they're spaced at such and
such an interval there is some
regularity what is it when is the next
blob gonna be
how big is the blob
what's going on so when we first started
plotting sequences in the oais
or converting them to music i made two
artificial sequences to display this
the music one is fur elisa converted to
sounds
that's sequence
a123456 if you're interested to display
the graph i made this sequence
and you say what an earth what sequence
is this well it's very simple
if you turn it around
it is a famous profile head of a woman
in profile
from the cleveland museum of art why'd
you pick that one because it's a clean
line and it's also a beautiful drawing
and have you found any uh properties to
the number oh
no
it'd be great if you found out it had
some equation or something yeah right
yeah all right then this is brilliant
i've sponsored today's video i'm going
to go back into this geometry
fundamentals course i've been doing it
before i'm doing all right
see what i'm up to here
27 unit cubes are packed together to
create it's like a rubik's cube if all
eight of the corner cubes are removed
how much will the surface area of the
figure increase
so i'm removing
three
i'm exposing
three i think it will stay the same
won't i
yes
oh yes
nice
should we have a look at what's next
how many of the following nets can fold
up into the square pyramid shown above
look people if you want to check out
this course or all the other ones on
brilliant have a look at this
look at all the courses they've got
look at them all
algebra fundamentals
algebra 1 algebra 2 trigonometry
pre-calculus also i will recommend the
daily challenges these are always great
fun
power tower comparison which of these
two expressions is larger 3 to the 3 to
the 3 to the 2 or 2 to the 3 to the 3 to
the 3.
what do you reckon i'm going to go
that one
am i right anyway people go to
brilliant.org
number file there's loads of stuff on
there for free but if you use that slash
number file you're going to get 20
off a premium membership and that
unlocks all the good stuff everything on
brilliant you've got access to
brilliant.org numberphile our thanks to
them for supporting this episode
[Music]
this was the second in a small trilogy
of videos with neil about amazing graphs
the third and final one is coming very
soon pretty obviously is never gonna
happen if you look at the graph and by
the way if you haven't checked out the
number file podcast yet the latest
episode of that is also an interview
with neil search numberphile on your
podcast player or you can watch them
here on youtube on our other channel
numberphile2.
[Music]